welcome everyone
my name is Jeremy Schwartz I'm an
associate professor of medicine at the
Yale School of Medicine and of
epidemiology at the Yale School of
Public Health I'm also the lead of the
faculty Network development of Faculty
Network development at the Yale
Institute for Global health I'm
delighted to welcome you to today's
conversation series event with Winnie
bianima the executive director of un
AIDS I'm coming to you today from Uganda
where I'm currently living and where
I've been engaged as a clinician
educator and researcher for nearly 20
years so the fact that winning be on
Yuma Our Guest is that Ugandan makes
this even more special for me
in addition to why GH today's event is
co-sponsored by the Walker fund at the
MacMillan Center and the center for
interdisciplinary research on HIV and
AIDS at Yale
it's a pleasure to be with all of you
here today
many of the drivers of gender inequality
in the HIV epidemic are the same as
those driving inequality in the covid-19
pandemic for example as we've seen
during the covid-19 pandemic women and
girls are at heightened risk of domestic
violence and inadequate access to
essential health care including HIV
prevention and sexual and reproductive
Health Services
to better prepare for the future during
today's conversation we will discuss the
imperative to address the underlying
social factors including gender
inequality that exacerbate these
pandemics
these issues of equity and social
determinants and their impact on Health
at home and around the world are
important for Yale faculty and students
The Faculty Network program at the Yale
Institute for Global health is proud to
support
almost a dozen networks that address
some of the greatest challenges in
global health
you're welcome to learn more about our
program on the ygh website
in tandem with this event today and in
close collaboration with Sira the center
for interdisciplinary research on AIDS
at Yale we will we launched the newest
addition to our faculty Network program
known as the Yale Global HIV AIDS
research Network or Garner for short
this new network will aim to bring
together Yale faculty and other partners
to support Global interdisciplinary
research on the implementation of HIV
prevention and treatment services that
reduce disparities
and work toward ending the HIV epidemic
to introduce Winnie bianima and to
moderate today's conversation I'll now
turn this over to my colleague mentor
and friend and one of the LA and one of
the leads of Garner Dr Luke Davis
thank you very much Jeremy uh hello
everyone my name is Luke Davis and I'm
associate professor of epidemiology and
a medicine at Yale I'm also the faculty
lead of the international research
program the center for international
research on AIDS at Yale and I'm a
clinician and researcher who's been
working in Uganda for about 17 years as
part of collaborations at mccarre
University on TV and HIV
on December 1st we will recommend we
will commemorate World AIDS day a day
when we will reflect and renew our
commitment to ending the HIV epidemic
four decades into the HIV response
inequality still persists for the most
basic services like testing treatment
and condoms and even more so for new
technologies young women in Africa
remain disproportionately affected by
HIV while coverage of dedicated programs
for them remains too low
we see similar issues in the response to
covet 19.
the theme for World AIDS Day this year
is equalize where we will recognize the
inequalities which perpetuate the AIDS
pandemic and make sure that they are not
inevitable
this year World AIDS day will be a call
to action a push for all of us to work
for the proven programs and strategies
that are needed to address inequalities
and help end AIDS
with that in mind it's my distinct
pleasure to introduce today's
distinguished guest Monique yanyima the
executive director of un AIDS
a passionate and long-standing champion
of social justice and gender equality
when he leads un's efforts to end the
AIDS epidemic by 2030. she believes that
Health Care is a human right and was an
early champion of a people's vaccine
against the coronavirus that is
available and free of charge to everyone
everywhere
before joining unaids
she she served as the executive director
of Oxfam International empowering people
to create a future that is secure just
and free from poverty when he was
elected for three terms and served 11
years in the parliament of her home
country Uganda
when he also led the establishment of
the African Union commission's
directorate of gender and development
and also served as director of gender
development at the UN development
program
she founded the forum for women in
democracy and influential Ugandan
non-governmental organization and has
been deeply involved in building Global
and African coalitions on social justice
issues
she's a passion Advocate and we're
incredibly honored to have her here with
us today welcome Winnie
Professor Luke Davis and Professor
Schwartz thank you for inviting me to be
part of this discussion
and you have to tell me because I'm not
smart enough to know how you managed to
be working in the Sunshine by Lake
Victoria and I'm sitting here in dump
and called Geneva you gotta show me how
you do that
thank you very much for having me and
I'm looking forward to
an exchange with young people at Yale
it's a privilege
how do you want this to go
well thanks Winnie it's wonderful to
have you with us the the theme of world
AIDS day today uh of 2022 is is equalize
and I wanted to start just by asking you
because you have been a champion for
this topic why is equality so critical
to ending the HIV AIDS epidemic and
maybe more broadly what do you think is
required to achieve equality
thank you for that question
I keep saying that um
HIV AIDS is an injustice
because it's today we have
tools for prevention
and we have tools for testing and tools
for treatment we don't have a vaccine
and we don't have a cure but what we
have in between these tools that we have
of every type that are will work for
children will work for adults who work
for gay people
all groups of people that these tools
are there but yet
last year we had 1.5 million new
infections most of them in Africa
and we had 650
000 people who died of age-related
illnesses so in spite of what we have
what science provides
we still have people newly infected
people dying and when you peel that and
see who is being infected who is dying
that's when you really see
inequalities driving HIV AIDS as indeed
they drive other pandemics as we saw in
covid as you rightly put it take Africa
and and first inequalities of every kind
gender inequalities income inequalities
racial inequalities and often where they
intersect is where you have the highest
vulnerability
so
I can give you some examples
in Africa
in sub-Saharan Africa
adolescent girls and young women are
three times as likely to acquire HIV as
adolescent boys and young men
that's just looking at a gender
inequality there
you also find between in the court of 15
and 19 years of age teenagers
that six out of seven newly infected
teenagers are girls
one is a boy six are girls it tells you
the high availability of girls and why
is that
it's driven by gender inequalities an
equal opportunity to education an equal
opportunity to sexual information an
equal an equal access to services so
these and
sexual violence which is actually a
result of a gender inequality
sexual violence is an indicator of
gender inequality
so you find that inequalities are
driving the high availability of
adolescent girls and young women four
thousand two hundred
adolescent girls young women are
infected every
you might say every year no
every month no every week four thousand
two hundred it's a crisis so then still
talking about inequalities
take the United States where you are
where many of the students are
black people are eight and a half times
more likely to be diagnosed with HIV
than white people
that's just taking a ratio difference
but if you take it further you take it
further you find
that
black gay men in the United States
have a one to two one in two risk of
Contracting HIV
across their lifetime one in two black
gay men in the richest country on Earth
this is a higher lifetime risk
than the average in Uganda low-income
country where I come from and almost as
high as the risk in Hot Spot regions
like South Africa and Zimbabwe
think about it when two axes of
inequality come together
sexual orientation
and race
you see the inequate the the
vulnerability the risk Rising much
higher so inequalities I could give you
more examples in Canada indigenous
people are several times more vulnerable
than the rest of the population and so
on and so on so we see and I have many
good examples but time so we see that
inequalities
denial of opportunities denial of
services
unequal access to Services
discrimination and stigma which result
in inequality of opportunity and
inequality in access to services or
drive HIV close them reduce them and
then you will see vulnerability and risk
dropping the March I'll give you one
last example
in Malaysia
where there's a concentrated epidemic
where same-sex relations are
criminalized
men who have sex with men are 72 times
72 times more likely to be living
with HIV than the general population not
72 times 72 percent more likely to be
living with HIV than the whole
population now you compare that with
Thailand another concentrated epidemic
where same-sex relations are not
criminalized men who have sex with men
are nearly 12 percent more likely to be
living with HIV 72 12. so just removing
the law that hunts down gay men
reduces their vulnerability so that is
why we say equalize equalize because
when you equalize when you close the
gaps you reduce the risk for others and
it also goes for deaths because deaths
are a result of not staying on treatment
and when you have full access to
treatment and you have an equal right to
treatment then again the risk of dying
is less so close the gaps close the gaps
by removing those laws that discriminate
that drive stigma
equalize opportunities
of Education of information of access to
health care of social protection
and then you will reduce the risk and
also the debts a long answer
thank you Winnie I I we we know that at
this time of year we're thinking about
the global HIV AIDS epidemic but of
course it's many different epidemics
affecting many different people and I
think you've highlighted some of the
unique you know barriers to delivery of
some of the the gains of science that
have been great in the field of HIV AIDS
but also gains in giving access to
people uh we need to we need to go
further in giving Equitable access to
everyone to these uh to these
life-saving interventions uh you know I
I guess as you talk about some of the
drivers um there that some of the
drivers are uh similar around the world
uh stigma may vary based on the
population but we know stigma and
discrimination whether it's adolescent
girls and young women as you were
talking about or uh uh black gay men uh
these are important factors um I guess
another factor that I'd love to hear you
talk a little bit about are economic
inequalities you mentioned that in your
first set of comments and I think we're
all familiar that we're facing a growing
worldwide economic crisis uh some
related to the recent code pandemic and
also to other factors uh war in Ukraine
Etc and this has had major impacts on
societies around the world in 2022 I
know that you often write and speak
about how such economic factors you know
whether we're talking about inflation or
uh more specific issues like Global
vaccine distribution how these can drive
health and inequities and inequalities
and I'm just curious uh given that
you've been very outspoken and a strong
Advocate how do your perspectives on
economic Justice influence your work in
your role at unaids
yeah
look um bloody raise that question and I
think here are two and AIDS
our approach to fighting HIV AIDS has
been
leaning very heavily on the biomedical
side Less on looking at
this social determinants these
structural barriers that need to be
removed so I we do not even have
sufficient data that we would use
to make this linkage of economic
inequality and vulnerability to HIV but
slowly we are pulling it together for
example we know
that overall people in urban areas have
significantly higher HIV prevalence than
rural
but that the urban poor have the highest
prevalence
of all in country after country Urban
poor we also know that in Namibia while
eight percent of
richer people non-poor if you could say
so in cities are living with HIV
15 of the urban poor have HIV
at last measure so it we see a
correlation between income inequality as
well as all the social factors that come
with poverty and higher vulnerability
but now if you also look at
who gets services
who gets Services you see them skewed
towards richer populations towards urban
populations
unless to rural poor that is also you
see that in terms of access Services who
is falling out of treatment for example
so in terms of economic injustices we
see this also at the national level
at the national level
you see countries that have the highest
burden
highest burden of HIV
struggling
to
pay debt
and that debt keeps increasing and
taking more and more out of the total
budget and squeezing out expenditures
on health expenditures on education
let me tell you what really shocked me
most was that in the midst of the crisis
the covet crisis
when countries that are rich were
pouring trillion 17 trillion was put
into the recovery cushioning the economy
of rich countries that's not talking
about the money put into buying uh the
coveted vaccine
developing countries
middle income and low income were
continuing to pay
debt to make debt repayments that were
four times
several times sometimes four times more
than the health their health budgets
imagine that in a time of illness where
there was a killer disease
plus other diseases like HIV
developing countries spent 27 and a half
of their total budget these are the poor
countries on debt repayments alone
about a third on debt repayments
that's as I said four times more than
the health spend
two times more than the education spend
and 20 12 times more than social
protection expenditure
it is an injustice in times of Crisis
even you at a family level when you are
in a mega crisis you go to the bank and
you schedule your debt you're given a
breathing space so that you recover and
then you can pay but this was not
possible
so we saw at the same time
by the way like we calculated that every
day
they reached G20 countries who are
sitting right now receive a
136 million dollars per day
in debt repayments from poor countries
who are struggling just to keep Services
going in the health sector so these are
Injustice we do not have a global
mechanism International Financial
mechanism for cushioning countries in
times of Crisis like pandemics
the IMF was created after the second
world war for the purpose of cushioning
countries from economic and other shocks
but look when kovid hit an entire Health
sectors were stretched completely Health
Care Systems
they came together the IMF they created
new money which they called special
drawing rights but they distributed it
according to the formula that exists
which is that the the biggest
shareholders get the biggest share so
they allocated the new money to the rich
ones who didn't need it
it was a scandal there was a lot of
pressure from many of us saying this is
not meaningful
the ones who need most this system of
cushioning isn't cushioning them
they came back now and said okay we
shall take our new money and we will
loan it loan it to you at a
concessionary rate imagine
SDS were created to give you money
without incurring debt but now they are
offering them to the low-income
countries
with the debt so there isn't a system
to cushion countries from pandemics and
that's really an injustice Health Care
should not be something
that
waits for other deals to this is life
the second example is about access to
medicines
I don't have to repeat the story of what
happened during kovid where a handful of
companies a handful
were allowed to decide how much vaccine
is produced at what price it is sold and
who can buy it
poor countries pulled their money
together Africa tried to pull money
together
they were told stand in the back of the
queue where richer countries took
everything
stocked up for themselves hoarded and
even expired drugs vaccines expired
as this and this happened because it is
allowed to happen because the trade
rules are now medicines life-saving
Health Commodities to be sold the way
you can sell a luxury item like a fancy
pen I'm holding here how can that be
but it's allowed we went to the trips
the WTO body that regulates intellectual
property to ask that there is a waiver
that allows all countries to take that
technology and produce it for themselves
no it was not allowed and who refused a
handful of countries whose companies
were reaping the billions so we saw fisa
make a
137 billion dollars in one year alone of
profit
from
a drug that had been produced with the
help of public resources from you
American taxpayers and German taxpayers
and we we we did an opinion poll
ordinary Americans Germans British
people were saying no Prophet should be
made from these vaccines before the
kovid
pandemic is over
but the companies held the Monopoly so
we argue against these mod this trade
rules that treat life-saving treatments
the same way they treat luxury items
like a Gucci handbag
we argue against such an injustice so
these are the things that are driving in
health globally we need to change the
global rules of trade we need also to
deal with the rules of Taxation
the these companies are not paying their
fair share of taxes they are able to
hide through many tax loopholes to
channel their profits from one country
to another put it in tax savings where
it's not taxed and that denies
small countries poor countries the
resources they need to pay for the
health of their people
we've calculated the billions that are
transferred to tax Havens every year
that developing countries lose it's
phenomenal it is several times over the
little Aid that is received
so sometimes people make Health an issue
of Aid yes I'm sitting here using an aid
check from rich countries but it
shouldn't be like that if we corrected
the tax injustices in the global
corporate tax system so you see that
Global rules enable or drive
inequalities which result in ill health
of some death of some and huge mega
profits for for a handful for few people
so that is what we mean about the
economic injustices in the global system
but also at the national level we have
our own governments that are not
prioritizing
Everybody's Health
in much of Africa
probably more than 33 countries
health
is paid for by the poorest people use a
fees
are collected for people to get and many
times people die
of malaria babies die of
of uh
diarrhea because a mother and or a
father can't afford this small user fee
charge and why is that you see money
being channeled through to other sectors
to large public administrations that you
don't need to defense expenditures
to all kinds of expenditures that are
less important than people's lives so
that's an injustice so we see how
economies they are the way they are
managed the rules in the trade system in
the in the taxation system the rules in
technology
how technology is produced intellectual
property rules all these work against
Justice and health and drive pandemics
such as HIV
I should stop there uh thank you Winnie
for highlighting uh you know I think uh
uh the the audience is chiming in and
appreciating your uh examples helping us
understand sort of this issue of
equality and I think particularly the
economic examples that the structural
factors that are you know baked into our
system at the macroeconomic level uh you
talked about some of the microeconomic
challenges that individuals you know
face and uh it's very I think helpful to
know what the barriers are and you've
also provided some solutions uh you know
this is a conversation with Winnie
vianima and I encourage those in the
audience uh to add your questions into
the chat uh we will get uh to a point in
a few minutes where we'll be taking
those but I do have a few more questions
that I would love to ask and one of the
factors I just want to give you one more
example because this is close to home
pharmaceutical companies in the United
States
of America
paid
more than a hundred
more than a hundred million dollars
in lobbying fees
lobbying
You Are Congress and Senate why
it is not because
they are paying legislators to find a
cure for malaria no it is so that they
can keep the price of medicines High
this is part of the problem the
corporate grid and the rules I was
talking about in the National systems
that allow certain things to happen
lobbying
by pharmaceutical companies to keep
prices High to keep taxes low hurts
ordinary citizens
Hearts not only other ordinary citizens
in the United States but all over the
world because they are lobbying about
prices of goods that they are going to
sell also to other countries so this
these are the rules that have to change
if people have to have a chance to
access medicine that is cheap that is
Affordable
sorry I wanted to give that example of
lobbying as a rule
that hurts
the health of people enormous amount of
money uh directed to
um something that is working against the
efforts that that uh all of us are
focused on I'm curious you know the
numbers of people displaced by War and
economic crisis and natural disasters is
is a topic that's uh of special interest
to a number of researchers here at Yale
and uh and the clinicians as well and
these numbers have kind of climbed over
the last decade we know that women and
girls comprise uh more than half of
refugee and displaced uh people
worldwide and they're also in that
context at a greater risk of
gender-based violence and uh I'm just
curious uh given your perspective I know
you worked in the area of humanitarian
crisis in your previous roles and
understand it well what can the global
Health Community do to support displaced
populations uh Refugee populations
populations living in humanitarian
crises that are increasing around the
world so that we can optimize the HIV
response in these sort of emergency type
settings
crises are
increasing
increasing
because of the complexity of issues of
War climate crises
poverty so people on the move are
increasing and those who are displaced
are also increasing we have to find ways
to get health services to reach them
and the surest way we we know from
experience of working on HIV AIDS is to
support communities to deliver services
for themselves we found this to work say
in Ukraine
Ukraine
is a country that has the second highest
burden of HIV AIDS in Eastern Europe
Eastern Europe and Central Asia that
region
it's set into Russia in terms of numbers
of people living with HIV
many are people who inject drugs or men
who have sex with men
when but Ukraine unlike Russia and many
of the other countries of Eastern Europe
had a system of delivering services
for HIV prevention and treatment that
were driven by communities Ukraine
empowered communities to lead services
so you would have gay communities sub
delivering services to gay people you
have people who inject drugs trained to
serve people who inject drugs and you
have
communities geographical communities
serving themselves
now when the war broke out
it was possible for many of us who are
in global Health to follow these
communities and continue to support them
because they were moving with their
people and they knew their people and
they could find them and most
importantly for a person living with HIV
who say crosses from Ukraine to Moldova
or from one part of Ukraine to another
the first is it this is not the first
thing you want to do to identify
yourself as I'm living with HIV
no it's your secret you fear stigma but
when you are fleeing with your community
and your community leaders who who run
the service are looking for you have
your cell number they will find you and
you'll be able to get on your treatment
so we found that it was quick for us in
a couple of months first they were cut
off from services but in a few months
they were back on Services because of
communities leading so for me the
biggest solution is of course to empower
communities to lead Services they have
the resilience to adapt when things go
bad but secondly of course is put the
resources down
to put down the resources that are
needed to reach people in trouble these
humanitarian spirit is so important and
I I think that this is how we our
humanities tested to be there to save
lives and the last one is to solve the
root causes the conflicts
the climate crisis stop roasting our
planet we've got to stop the
displacement
back to you
thank you Winnie I really appreciate
your highlighting the the power of
peer-led interventions uh in so many
ways I think there's a number of
examples in our HIV AIDS Community here
at Yale uh specifically with the respect
to the war in Ukraine uh responding to
the needs of people who uh inject drugs
and their need for opiate Agnes therapy
supporting people on HIV care and then
just responding more broadly uh many in
the uh Ukrainian and Russian communities
here have responded uh and I know
there's other examples we've seen it in
Uganda as well I wanted to ask you a bit
about
um uh you know given the audience that
we have here and I think the Ford
looking view of world AIDS day what are
your comments about how we might educate
and train in the next generation of
students researchers providers Advocates
and community members uh kind of
highlighting what you had said there
about about peer interventions
um how can we harness this group and and
uh help them contribute best to
meaningfully addressing inequalities as
we're focusing on today and improving
the global HIV AIDS response
that's a very hard one because I'm not a
professor I don't know how to teach
about young people
I think that first of all
um
young people are today not getting
as much information about HIV AIDS
as an older generation
and secondly young people particularly
in Africa but I also see it in other
continents
are not getting
sexuality education
which is critical for life
young people are going through school
without knowing about their bodies
especially girls and knowing about how
to live a healthy life
and how to handle their sexuality as
they become teenagers
young boys
grow up
with
toxic masculinities they understand
their
their must they are gender in a violent
way
and do not have
a healthy peaceful masculinity so
there's a need for sexuality education
for boys and girls in all our schools so
that boys grow up with a healthy notion
of masculinity and also a a positive
attitude towards Health seeking and
girls also need to be empowered about
their bodies and to know how to own
their body and make choices for
themselves these things aren't happening
and
lives are being lost of young people in
terms of
um
at a higher level
I think that we need the space
the academic freedom to use it
to discuss difficult issues
like human rights
lgbtq rights
in a country where
lgbtql
lgbtq people are criminalized
you want to have
a debate
at a university like makere where maybe
you are
there should be the freedom for young
people to debate these issues because it
is from centers of of intellectual
centers like universities that we can
challenge stigma and discrimination I
think
education on human rights on women's
rights and the and using the space the
academic space
to vocalize to debate to
I mean why can't there be
a pride
a pride
much at Mercury if it can't happen
outside within the gates of the
University why can't it happen
so we really need to challenge young
people about
human rights
and women's rights I see young people
and I get mad young people in my country
young boy young men
who are little Patriarchs in the making
who they already are they've got an
attitude about being Superior to women
this is the education coming from
tradition religion and so on we have to
we have to challenge it this is an equal
world so I I see the importance of
teaching human rights to all students
science students art students and
women's rights and debating
this is what I can say about hell
because health
is ultimately a human right
it is not just something to trade and to
give away to rich people it's a human
right and we must Center it around human
rights and
focus on it as a human right
thank you for those inspiring words we
we wanted our shift in our last 20
minutes so together to open up the
questions to some audience members and
I'll start with one from Edward
kabagambe who is asking about
cardiovascular diseases as we all know
these are emerging as major
comorbidities and HIV AIDS patients as
uh we've been able to enable patients to
live longer with HIV AIDS and the
question is are there coordinated
cardiovascular disease control efforts
uh in uh especially thinking about low
and middle income countries for
preventing cardiovascular disease and
HIV populations uh I think specifically
uh Edward Edmund is interested in high
blood pressure and stroke
what is the question
are there coordinated uh cardiovascular
disease control efforts that are
happening to prevent cardiovascular
disease and HIV populations I I know
there are some activities that are going
on uh faculty members uh here at Yale
but uh more broadly what is your
perspective on uh integrating care for
chronic diseases especially
cardiovascular diseases in people living
with HIV
I think as um
as the years go and we are now 40 years
since HIV was first isolated
and as treatment
treatments improve and people live
longer and longer lives with HIV the
issues of comorbidities have become very
important that people living HIV
and how other diseases affect them
including high blood pressure and and
others this is becoming more and more
important in understanding
of course for us
as a pro a response a Global Response on
HIV AIDS the big ones that we pay
attention to are TB
and HIV because it's a strong
correlation the most debts eight eight
related deaths are deaths from TB
and then now increasingly we see that
mental health is so important
for many many people who live on
treatment for a very long time
it affects their mental health and this
is something we have not worked on for
long about high blood pressure I think
that is probably lower down the list of
priorities that we work on in in the
global HIV response but it's probably an
important area and I have not read much
about it
well thanks for your thoughts there I I
I'd love to also to talk a little bit
about we you know we highlighted and you
highlighted earlier this issue of of
Allison girls and young women but but
women more generally being much more
vulnerable uh to the effects of HIV and
uh one of the questioners is asking just
given this disproportionate uh impact
could you comment a little bit on
coordinated and concentrated efforts to
tailor treatments specifically to women
one example is given is sort of breaking
the cycle of maternal to child
transmission but I know there's many
other women specific examples it'd be
interesting to hear your perspective on
you know that takes me back also to the
social determinants
do you know that it is a shame
that children are left behind in the HIV
response that globally 75 of all people
living with HIV are on treatment
but the number for children is just 50
percent
50 so half the children living with HIV
today are not on treatment they are
dying and we still have countries many
countries even in spite of the treatment
that is there that still have mothers
transmitting HIV to their babies
and you have to ask yourself why cause
back to inequalities when you look at
those countries that have
High rates of mother to child
transmission
they of countries they are the same
countries or those are the con those
countries have
a high
High well let me put it this way yeah
High numbers of
teenage mothers
teenage mothers you find that the
biggest number of
the mothers who have transmitted
HIV to their babies are actually
children themselves
they are girls who've given birth
There are 16 they are 17 they are 18.
and this
is and they are poor and this is the
reason why they transmit
first as you know if you are living in
Africa if a girl gets pregnant
perhaps 7 out of ten
chances are that she will leave home
she will go stay with an aunt she'll God
stay with her sister should go to hide
at her boyfriends she's shunned by the
family and the community
that movement alone means that she moves
away from where she has Services where
she knows she's in hiding
those are factors that lead to lack of
to not accessing Services because if she
went for antenatal she would get that
quickly put tested and put on treatment
and she wouldn't transmit so we have to
solve many issues not enough to put
medicine in the clinics Arabs in the
clinics we have to solve those issues of
teenage mothers and we when we don't
connect these two we keep saying but why
are the numbers coming down
we have some programs I've seen uh some
programs where they tell our mother
to bring
the man who made you pregnant
they disappear they don't come back
because the circumstances are that she
does not even tell whoever made her
pregnant that she's HIV positive
so addressing those social factors
addressing those barriers that stop
young women from coming forward
to save their babies is important and
once the baby is born positive
they also fear the stigma of taking the
child to be put on treatment
because then the child will know and
then her secret will be known I've just
come from Jamaica I went to a
community-led service
I met five users of the service
two of them were women who had been
using the center for 18 years they'd
been going there for their arvs they
laughed they joked they were at home
with the the leaders of the center the
service providers when we talked I asked
him I said
they had children I said do you tell
young women in your community
to be careful
to
save themselves to prevent to ask for
safe sex do you tell them they said what
we cannot say the word HIV
nobody in our community knows that we
are HIV positive if we talked about HIV
we would be known and we would be
shunned imagine
18 years
their communities know nothing
their own their friends who know their
secret are those who come to the center
so
imagine this kind of stigma
what that means for a child growing with
HIV who is HIV positive
it's too hard so many moms will not tell
their child and will not let them have
treatment and will watch them die
so we have to address those issues
of stigma
fight stigma
fight discrimination before we can have
everyone come forward to get service
yeah
Wendy there's a lot of interest in sort
of the effects of covid-19 some people
asking about whether it affects HIV
outcomes and what's the burden of
covid-19 on people with HIV but but
maybe more broadly quite a few questions
about how covid-19 has affected the way
we deliver HIV Services whether you're
thinking about HIV testing or even some
of the social uh factors uh uh some are
highlighting just the the role of
domestic violence kind of during the
covid-19 pandemic maybe the broad
question would be then is how how has
covid-19 changed uh the task that you
you face and that we all face to kind of
address HIV AIDS uh going forward
let me start with what is positive
so that excites me some things
changed for the better from kovic in our
HIV response
some policies for example that we had
been advocating and that we know would
help people to stay on treatment and and
be safe and be virally suppressed
finally came to happen like multi-month
dispensing we had been telling many
governments that please allow people who
are regular in coming for their
treatment to get a stock of drugs for
six months or at least start with three
months so they don't have to come every
month but many governments fearing that
they are not in good control of the
supply chain wouldn't do it
so they were still requiring people to
come every month sometimes every twice a
month but when kovid hit and
public safety measures required people
to lock down people then they had no
choice but start rolling out multi-month
dispensing and then they realize that it
works
that it it actually saves them and
because people will not come who are not
coming to the clinic then the second
other Innovations came in you got people
I'm always proud to tell this story in
India
people living with HIV getting on their
bikes collecting
the arvs for a group of them and going
around Distributing to each other so
they'll take turns
these were Innovations and then using
the phone
you finally telemedicine came to health
to HIV
because now they were using the phone to
locate people to drop off supplies
because people fear stigma they tell you
where to drop it they pick it up but
it's all on the phone so all these
Innovations came in the way services are
provided as a result of the public
safety measures
but bad things also happened
violations of human rights people were
already stigmatized tend to be targeted
scapegoated when there's fear and panic
in society so you got
gay men
suddenly becoming more oppressed more
victimized you got sex workers being
thrown out of their homes and being told
that they are Victors of the the
coronavirus I came to Uganda to see
President museveni because there were
there was a group of about 40 or so gay
men who were found hiding in a shelter
and arrested and taken to prison for
nothing
and horrible horrible tests were done on
them
so I went to see him
and asked him to have them released then
he said to me I need to tell you this
anecdote
he said
but um
they are in prison because they violated
coveted rules our coveted laws here
they are not supposed to be so many in
one building
can you not
I said Mr President these are people who
run away from their homes their inner
shelter and say well continue your needs
build the many houses
what kind of question is that I said we
don't build houses for people this is a
a kind person who's giving them a
shelter
and that's where they stay
I said well we're going to see but this
is a breach of our rules we don't want
many people crowding
then I looked at him as if the president
he was in his state house in the table
same Mr President but down the road
there on bugonga Road
there's a group of 50 women in one house
why haven't you arrested them
said what who are those I said the nuns
they're in a covered
and he burst out and laughed he said you
got to me
totally ridiculous that gay men staying
in a shelter where a risk but in all
these other places people were they were
religious communities nobody was
touching them
so discrimination discrimination was
rampant and we saw the violation of
Human Rights we issued a report about it
drew attention to it so those were but
in terms of the general response to HIV
AIDS some things also
hurt us we're thrown off track because
governments run out of money both the
donors were pouring money into saving
their people
and we're putting in their economies to
keep them growing or at least stable and
we are cutting the money the little
money that goes to
supporting HIV responses in developing
countries we fought to keep this money
flowing and we are still fighting but we
were hard because many countries still
depend on
the American Pro program pepsa as well
as a global fund and we were seeing but
actually I have to say this credit to
the United States government in the
middle of all that they actually
increased their contribution to some of
our work but some other countries
reduced
we also saw
ly got the same story of what had
happened with the RVs
when they were first produced
and it took 10 years before they became
available in the South because of the
price because of the Monopoly of
companies we saw it play out again and
we had tried to say let's learn the best
lesson
12 million people died mostly in Africa
while we waited for the price to come
down does it have to happen again but no
we didn't learn the lesson so again we
saw the same rules working to Heart a
global response
but now we are we we came back fighting
we are now fighting for long-acting
injectables
long-acting injectables for prevention
are now available if you are in New York
you can have it you can get a job and
for two months
you're safe you can have sex and you
will not with someone who has HIV but
you won't contract it
if you are in London you can have it
it's affordable
but it's not available for a gay man yet
in South Africa or in Uganda or in Kenya
the price is still too high and the
countries cannot import it yet we are
fighting for this price to come down
long acting
long-acting antiretrovirals will be a
game changer for young women and girls
because young girls and young women are
most of the time hiding don't want to be
known that either they are having sex or
they are positive
and and can't control
can't control can't negotiate safe sex
but imagine having an injection
that prevents
for six months
or you have the eravi and you don't have
to swallow a tablet nobody has to see if
you're a girl you're not swallowing a
tablet you're not causing attention to
yourself but you get a job every six
months it will be a game changer but it
will be available first in rich
countries will have to fight to get the
price down
some people died before the price comes
down but we'll do it we have to do it a
new young people must be part of these
campaigns and it was the alliance of gay
men
in American Europe
with people in the South that brought
the price of antiretrovirus down and the
leadership of people like President
Mandela so it will take Global alliances
to end AIDS
to bring prices down to have access to
medicines to the best of Science and to
remove these laws and policies that
create barriers for people
thank you this has been a remarkable
conversation I think we could easily go
for another hour uh the audience hasn't
been inspired by your comments and I
think you've given both a general
framework for thinking about where we're
falling short namely addressing equality
and also giving us room for hope that
some of the victories that have been won
in the past for standing up for economic
Justice and standing up for the uh those
those who are adversely affected by
stigma and discrimination that we can
carry those forward with with new
technologies and do better
um we thank you so much for joining us
today and we'll be following your work
closely and uh we'll take forward your
words with inspiration
well thank you so much and greetings to
my brothers and sisters in Uganda
[Music]
thank you for for being with you and I I
enjoy engaging with
students and intellectuals thank you
thank you very much